how many times do you simulate this
before i'm assuming thousands whatever
it is or and but like
um how do those simulators work and are
they
are you like practice landing in like
the middle of a desert um or do you have
like a
like a i'm thinking like a movie studio
or you can like a big
warehouse where you can adjust the
atmosphere in there to test how do you
guys practice for this
okay well let me tell you what we don't
do
well what we can do because it's too
difficult too expensive and not not
not worth it is to try to to
to exercise that that whole sequence
here on earth
the the conditions on earth of
atmosphere and gravity are so far off
we don't need it's worthless it's
expensive
so the best we we do right the worst we
can do
and what we do is first of all for each
component
of of this system we do tests right like
for example for the parachute we do a
test that try to mimic
the conditions when we open the
parachute as much as we can
right to make sure that it's the right
design and is
and it's built properly too and the same
with the landing radar
we put the landing radar in the
helicopter and we try to replicate the
conditions that the radar is going to
see on mars and we fly through the
mojave desert under different terrains
you know different velocities and then
and then we process the data from those
tests and we
we build mathematical models of
of of that component for each one of
these components that we test
separately we build mathematical models
and then we put it in in
a simulation right all those
mathematical models we put them together
and then we make the system land in a
simulation
right where we model all the components
and also we have to model
the marginal environment like where
we're landing we're gonna get winds
and the the atmosphere density is
changing right
and the the places where we don't know
exactly where things are which is
we don't know anything exactly we
actually statistically we add noise
we errors that we've
that try to envelop the uncertainty and
the error in each component like for
example the
the the winds we don't know exactly so
we add a random component to the winds
and then we we use a technique called
monte carlo which is
from the casino so it's actually it's
after that which essentially it becomes
a statistical
where we make the system land thousands
if
not tens of thousands of times in the
simulation
and then we look at statistically which
one landed properly and which one
landed you know failed right so
statistically we can say well 99
you know nine percent of landed okay
then you're good and sometimes you know
here there are
you know we are only having success with
90 okay what is that 10 percent that is
not working
i said do we have a deficiency in the
uh in the uh on the
uh simulation or or just simply that the
sign is improper so we need to go fix
the design
uh uh and so that's that's what we use
that's the best we use
that's why we call the seven minutes of
terror one of the many reasons
is that the we haven't done it
essentially we have to do it the
computers don't do it but you have it
right exactly so then that's why we are
so concerned that it's not gonna work
because if we forgot a little piece of
physics
we have a small error in that simulation
that doesn't
expose our our mistake
then mars will tell us about our mistake
and it's too late by then right so
it's and uh so that's that's why it's so
so unnerving it's just the fact that we
the first time we try
is when we try it right in and when we
are
betting all those years of work and
sacrifice
in seven minutes and i i know that
feeling when you work so hard on
something and there's an
element of luck to it or or circumstance
but when it hits it's it's the best
feeling in the world
have you worked on projects that have
gone the other way i was never
involved in a in you know working in it
i've always you know
i've been consultant in in one of them i
guess that did not work
but all the ones that i worked on have
worked
so i've been being successful and it's
actually kind of i mean i'm trying to
still explain to myself why i mean i was
very nervous a day of the landing and it
had nothing to do
in terms of not trusting the the
engineers working on it in this one
uh some of them you know uh my friends
and then
had tremendous respect for them but i
was very nervous and
maybe it's because we you know there are
many reasons why
maybe one was simply you know we just
been so lucky we've been very successful
landing these rovers
is our is our luck going to run out at
some point
i know there's no very scientific way of
thinking right but we are humans after
all
you know with emotions and sometimes uh
when we
after we finish doing all that we can do
with our brain right
then the heart takes over right and it
starts telling you things
and making you lose sleep at night and
then you have to say no but wait a
second i know that this is
the same as before and we tested this
and we tested and these guys did a
tremendous job in there
and i trust them and they work really
hard and i i saw them doing it
so then you kind of the brain takes over
again
and tells the heart you know we're gonna
be fine but then when you land it's all
about the heart right it's not about the
brain
it's room of emotional emotional
scientists and engineers which i love
um i think that's what's so i don't know
endearing about it frankly let me back
up like what what is the um
the purpose of the perseverance rover
which just landed it landed in feb
february 18th of 2021 just a couple
weeks ago
what what's the end goal for nasa and
for for
us to to get from this rover on mars
all of these missions have multiple
goals but there are some main goals the
main goal here is
in the the previous rovers right from
pathfinder
to curiosity they're the objective
they're all associated with the with the
goal of
determining whether there was life on
mars
3.5 billion years ago four billion years
ago when the conditions of mars
were you know were very different it was
a you know they had an atmosphere it was
a
they have oceans and lakes and
uh and uh it was a warm planet
and very similar to the same con
to the conditions of earth at that time
where on earth life was starting right
so the question is well if the
conditions were there
then there is a chance that life
actually also
originated on mars at the same time then
mars changed
right became lost its atmosphere became
very dry
and cold right and but the question is
during that time did life
you know originated on mars and uh and
that's
a question it's very important question
that the scientists
not just the scientists but right i mean
the philosophers everybody wants to know
what we are alone in the universe
is is life just a pure
terrestrial phenomena right and and
that's it right i mean it's it's a very
difficult
the condition has to be perfect
incredible and
and only happens in the whole universe
only happen on earth right it's probably
unlikely that that's the case but it
would be awesome to prove that that's
not the case just by showing within our
solar system
that life actually took hold in more
than one place
right so that's why we're interested on
mars now the previous missions after
curiosity
the main objective was not detecting
life itself
it didn't have the capability the
instruments to do that but
to detect whether the conditions uh
for life to uh to originate on mars
happen
in the in the distance parts past right
so
one of them was finding water that
stayed
which it didn't state that instead of
water did exist right
and they found check you know water
exists you know right ph
so not too salty not too acidic wow
perfect for life
you know i i need i it lasted millions
of years which is
time is always important in the recipe
of life all of the things are
were there so now now with perseverance
we need to go answer the
it's time to answer the final question
okay cool
but was there a life or not right and
perseverance is going to try to do that
in two ways
one it has instruments on board more
sophisticated instruments
that work in a different way than the
previous uh to
to look for they call it biosignatures
which are you know
again to non-expert like me they are
indirect
evidence that that you know of minerals
and the way they were deposited
that were the action most likely the
action of biological
uh you know processes
right so that's and that's what we call
bios biosignatures
detecting life on mars is very difficult
right but
trying to find biosignatures it's it's
the best we can do at this point
why is detecting life so difficult there
it's
life itself the definition of life is
difficult and uh
and it's not you know it seems that it's
not uh
you know and it's not an easy you know
it's controversial thing
right so the best way to to but and also
because
being able to say there was life on mars
or be able to say
we know a place that there was life that
is not earth it's such a huge statement
that the amount of proof
you need is is overwhelming right so the
second
way that perseverance is going to help
is it's going to take these
samples of soil and rock
encapsulate them into in these cylinders
and and and seal them
such that another mission that we are
working on it called mars sample return
is going to take these samples
and bring them back to earth now here on
earth
we have all the instruments
sophisticated instruments we can
make the measurements argue the
scientists with you know and and now you
can
have you know we we feel that if they're
if they're you know if there was life
fossils in that in those samples
we'll be able to come up with a
scientific consensus
right and uh and try to do bringing
those instruments to mars
is very very difficult it's much easier
to bring a piece of
mars to the instruments on earth so
that's
the second way that perseverance is
going to help
answer these questions
[Music]
you